hannover ist luca eine liebe freunde ich
darf euch heute schon wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen so einer
weiteren episode luca redet mit dem
clever
ich habe bereits ein bisschen mit ihm
geredet und zwar habe ich gefragt wie
geht die rare daraufhin nicht so gut ich
hab da natürlich gefragt warum nicht gut
und daraufhin meinte er weil ich noch
nie eine freundin hatte
oder es tut mir leid und ich hätte gern
eine freundin warum habe ich dann
geantwortet und er dann ich weiß
das ergibt keinen sinn ganz kurz
übrigens an alle unter euch die
deutschen nicht so gut sind es gibt
nicht das wort das macht keinen sinn es
heißt immer das ergibt keinen sinn nur
falls euer deutsche gerade irgendwo
ankommen sollte dass ihr wisst ihr
gelernt hier auch was bei mir doch
oft zurück
wo lüge ich denn also er ich stelle mir
einfach nur ein paar fragen mit allem
ich lief mit dem universum wieso lüge
ich mit dem universum werden sagt
einfach gerade ich er macht war sie
alles weil du eine frau bin
das macht alles keinen sinn ich bin ein
mann schreibt einfach mal mit einem
punkt hinter dass er weiß dass es mir
ernst ist na dann
der ssd plötzlich
laurin ist bei dir hochwasser
wie falsch verbunden was willst du von
mir schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal in
großbuchstaben mit drei fragezeichen
nichts
im kopf kommt ok neuanfang punkt punkt
punkt schreibe ich einfach mal ja also
wir fangen einfach mal mit einem ganz
normalen smalltalk an halo sogar mit
einem kleinen smiley dahinter hallo okay
na wie geht es dir schreibe ich einfach
mal ddr personen geht es gut und dir
auch gut was machst du so wir müssen ja
langsam so ein bisschen rein kommen mit
dir schreiben ja das mache ich auch
das mache ich auch
cool
ja aber
ich schreibe
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter
und fragen wer genau bis du ich will
wissen mit wem ich hier schreibe ich bin
ein mensch okay die junge oder mädchen
frage ich einfach mal ein mädchen okay
wie alt bist du ein bisschen unser check
mit wem ich es überhaupt zu tun habe
selber beantwortet sage ich nicht
er unter oder über 30 mache ich mal sagt
du zuerst wie alt du bist 25 jahre alt
bin ich wenn die war clever wortwahl
schauen wir es jetzt als antwort kommt
da bin ich wirklich gespannt darauf ein
alter reagierst du siehst aus wie 40
jahre
hmm
es war einfach nicht mehr witzig ne
ich weiß ist er ganz fanny mit seiner
traurigen musik und schwarz weiß und
zwar bei ist es einfach nicht das
einzige das mich gerade noch so ein
bisschen auf den beinen halten kann ist
bei foot die freundlicherweise das
heutige video unterstützen bei der
schlechteste kooperations übergang den
ich je gesehen habe jetzt wahrscheinlich
letzte schon auf meine instagram account
gesehen und zwar trinke ich weiß schon
seit längerem es ist einfach eine
ausgewogene trink mal zeit die ich
beispielsweise jetzt gerade also ich
schon am pc einfach so zwischendurch
trinken kann und die mich für drei bis
fünf stunden satt hält das ist wirklich
eine vollwertige trinkt mahlzeiten kein
protein shake oder hinten diät getränke
oder so es gibt diese drinks sind zwei
verschiedenen größen und es gibt sogar
vier verschiedene vegane varianten ihrer
kapazitäten weiter weg vom 20 karina
berger
ist bei der 25
und jetzt könnt ihr einfach mal in die
infobox und ein video hier gucken denn
dort findet ihr einen link zu weich wird
und da könnte es ganz einfach mal
ausprobieren und ich habe sogar code für
eule mit laser luca 10 erhaltet ihr zehn
prozent rabatt auf das standardsortiment
niltal großes danke an drei für den
support und jetzt gehts weiter mit dem
video wir erinnern uns da clever bord
hat mich ja vorhin beleidigt und gesagt
dass ich mit meinen 25 jahren aussehe
wie 40 dann sagt du doch mal wie alt du
bist das würde mich jetzt wirklich mal
interessieren ich hab's ja vorhin schon
gesagt er meint ja sagt du zuerst 15
das ist zu jung also wir schreiben hier
komplett normal und alles easy aber was
ich fühle mich ein
wenig unwohl schreibe ich einfach mal
ich mache zwar jetzt gerade hier nicht
so soll nun
warum
einfach so
sein vater
[Musik]
hier sind zehn jahre auseinander
wie hier
hat er jetzt weil ich gesagt habe wir
sind zehn jahre auseinander dass ich
zehn jahre alten bruder ich habe jetzt
einfach mal die seite aktualisiert und
neuen chat angefangen und habe direkt
geschrieben guten tag herr bot daraufhin
wie geht es ihnen ich gut und ihnen und
der clever bot daraufhin ich bin gut
danke
er hat also ein bisschen an der frage
vorbei geredet ich würde allerdings
sagen dass ich direkt wieder mit dem
haus an die türen platze und einmal
direkt sage wer bist du bzw das ganze
frage weil ich will wissen mit wem ich
hier schreibe der mensch ok junge oder
mädchen fragt einfach mal ich will
wissen mit wem ich sie zu tun habe ein
mädchen okay wie alt bist du wenn ich
fragen darf natürlich noch fragt ja eine
dame nicht nach dem alter so etwas fragt
man ich hab noch extra gesagt wenn ich
fragen darf
manchmal vergesse ich wirklich dass sie
mit dem computer schreiben und ich muss
gar nicht auf höflichkeit oder so achten
deswegen gefahr jetzt einfach was ist
ein alter 990
ich bin
und weil ich bin ein
[Musik]
wir drehen uns ein bisschen im kreis
genau das schreibe ich jetzt auch
einfach mal wir drehen uns im kreis noch
lange nicht was soll dann heißt noch
lange nicht also wir reden uns nicht im
kreis irgendwie komme die ganze zeit den
gleichen fragen ja warum nein warum also
ich habe gefragt wir drehen uns im kreis
und selber ja warum ich nein warum weil
ich dich nicht mag
ich habe jetzt einfach richtig zurück
ich dich auch nicht die esel ja dann
sind wir uns ja einig
machst du gerade so
treiben das ist auch die standard
antwort darauf schreibt mir bitte mal
themen oder fragen unten in die
kommentare ich will einfach wissen wer
hinter dieser ganzen sache hier schreibe
ich ja sagen wir mal wer steckt hinter
deinen nachrichten ist dass irgendein
ding sign notgeil
[Musik]
welche rein geraten
wäre ja
vorausgesagt ersten mädchen ist es jetzt
ein junge oder mädchen bei valeria hört
sich nach einem mädchennamen kann
es macht alles keinen sinn an der stelle
ich das heute wieder jetzt endlich
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
mal wieder hier sorgt screen actor
clever bot mit mir luca gefallen hat
dann hat man einen daumen hoch oder die
video hier da abonniert main kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn die neue
videos nicht verpassen wollten morgen 18
uhr geht es weiter mit minecraft mit
luca staffel 2 also schaltet auf jeden
fall wieder hier ein auf meinem kanal
und wenn ihr wollt dass ich demnächst
mal wieder ein neues terror video
hochladen also wirklich mit der klamotte
website dann schreibt er geld und den
kommentare jetzt sind wir allerdings
erst metro
könnten wo draufklicken wo ihr wollt
mir doch den smiley dann könnte mich
abonnieren oder halt auf das dings das
andere video
ist beides irgendwie nicht so das gelbe
vom ei aber naja
englisches nottwil lu fromberg als den
geist balda